avec vos hélène frade bonjour hélène
bonjour pauline à la une de la presse
d'abord le duel à distance entre
emmanuel macron et jean luc mélenchon
alors que se tient dimanche ici en
france le second tour des élections
législatives
si ce n'est pas un troisième tour de
présidentielle ça y ressemble
furieusement alors que leur formation le
sait sont au coude à coude le président
est le chef de file de la nouvelle
alliance de la gauche s'affrontent par
médias interposés emmanuel macron la vue
depuis le tarmac d'orly dans un discours
préparé en urgence d'après le figaro le
président en appelle au sursaut
républicain pour préserver sa majorité à
l'assemblée et déclare je le cite que
rien ne serait pire que d'ajouter un
désordre français au désordre mondial le
chaos c'est macron réplique jean luc
mélenchon dans une interview au parisien
aujourd'hui en france le patron de la
france insoumise en appel lui aux 25
millions de français qui se sont
abstenus au premier tour pour que la
nuque décroche la majorité au palais
bourbon dimanche prochain lui est arrivé
en tête du premier tour dans sa
circonscription le ministre des
solidarités actuelle damien abad est
l'objet de nouvelles accusations
d'agression sexuelle le site d'info
mediapart dit avoir recueilli de
nouveaux témoignages mettant en cause
son comportement avec les femmes dont
celui du l'élu centriste qui dénonce une
tentative de viol en 2010 damien damien
abad a déjà été accusé de viol par deux
femmes peu après sa nomination et il
réfute ces nouvelles accusations tout
aussi infondées selon lui que les
précédentes et il dénonce le calendrier
soigneusement choisis de ses
publications je le cite évidemment cinq
jours avant le second tour des
législatives
à la une également on en parlait dans le
journal avec damian à l'instant
l'annulation hier soir à la dernière
minute hélène par la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme d'un vol sans ces
expulsés des demandeurs d'asile du
royaume uni vers le rwanda à ce revers
pour le gouvernement britannique est
accueilli avec soulagement et amertume
et amertume par le daily or qui voit
dans cette affaire une farce cruelle
joué par les conservateurs sur le dos
des réfugiés dont steve devait prendre
place hier dans un avion spécialement
affrété pour un coût faramineux estimé à
près de 500 mille livres par le tabloïde
les conservateurs eux évidemment fulmine
contre la décision de la cour européenne
le daily mail livre sa version de la
journée d'hier à 7h36 du matin un canot
pneumatique rempli de migrants et si à
l'image s'est dangereusement approché
d'un super tankers dans la manche au
risque d'être renversé
quelques heures plus tard à 22h05 très
précisément le projet du royaume uni de
mettre fin à ce trafic mortels je cite
et est sabotée par les juges intrusif de
strasbourg question du tabloïd où l
humanité là dedans la décision du
royaume uni de sous traiter le dossier
des demandeurs d'asile au rwanda est
dénoncée par tripy tor books avec ce
dessin où les membres du gouvernement de
boris johnson ont pris place à bord d'un
avion de rwanda airlines la seule façon
morale de remplir un aller simple pour
le rwanda selon le dessinateur des
vibreurs nuit est à bord du vol t1 russe
55 ou la ministre des affaires
étrangères les stress cet office
d'hôtesse de l'air le climat à
l'extérieur et non démocratique leur
local est à l'indifférence et nous
n'avons pas encore quitté le royaume uni
nous irons à kigali dans le journal de
7h30 beaucoup de réactions hélène aussi
et pour cause al'annonce de la visite le
mois prochain de joe biden en arabie
saoudite la volte face du président
américain qui avait promis on s'en
souvient avant son élection de traiter
le royaume en état paria est accueillie
avec ironie par le wall street journal
qui l'eût cru les etats-unis ont besoin
d'alliés au moyen-orient le quotidien
américain estime que le revirement de
joe biden aurait été moins gênant s'il
avait été plus réaliste dès le début au
lieu je cite de s'incliner devant le
dédain de la gauche américaine envers
ryad le wall street journal pauline qui
se fait l'avocat du prince héritier
m'hamed ben salman présentait comme un
allié certes peu recommandable selon les
normes américaines notamment raison de
sa complicité présumée dans la stinat du
journaliste jamais rh oggi mais
également comme un dirigeant qui aurait
apporté un niveau de réformes sociales
inédit jusque là y compris en matière de
droits des femmes le financial times lui
y voit surtout dans la volte-face de joe
biden la preuve du dilemme énergétique
de l'occident notamment des états unis
contraint par la guerre en ukraine aso
fournir davantage auprès des régimes
autocratiques un pacte faustien selon le
quotidien britannique
un mot enfin de la hausse depuis
plusieurs jours ici en europe ça faisait
longtemps qu'on n'en avait pas parlé
hélène du nombre de contaminations aux
copies de 19 je les appelle parce qu'on
n'a pas le temps d'en parler simplement
vous dira mot de cette étude du figaro
qui fait état d'une étude donc qui
indique que près de quatre sondés sur
dix 38% disent qu'ils arrivent d'éviter
délibérément les informations contre
seulement 27 % en 2017 des résultats qui
représente un vrai défi pour nous autres
journalistes paulina qui avons tendance
à considérer que les sujets les plus
importants les guerres les crises
politiques et autres pandémies sont
précisément ceux qui semblent agir comme
des repoussoirs pour nos bien aimées
téléspectateurs vous voulez la légèreté
qu'à cela ne tienne avant de vous
laisser filer je vais partager avec vous
cette info essentielle l'essentiel en
tout cas pour les amateurs de crocs dont
vous êtes pauline la mise sur le marché
d'un modèle de crocs donc sur le thème
j'en perds mon latin des margaritas
cocktail estivale s'il en est alors ce
modèle comprend six breloques un
minuscule parapluie en papier arfaux
glaçons un nouveau bouteille perroquet
qui marche un verre et la petite salle
hier approprié pour être à la mode est
évidemment totalement à l'aise par les
chaudes journées d'été